Let us discuss how
successful eHarmony has been.
By 2004, eHarmony has made
over $100 million in sales,
and by 2009, it has reached
the $1 billion mark.
In 2005, 90 eHarmony
members married every day.
In 2007, 236 eHarmony
And finally 2009, 542 eHarmony
members married daily.
The following
statistics demonstrate
the edge that eHarmony has.
It has 14% of the U.S.
online dating market.
The only competitor
with a larger portion
is match.com with a 24% share.
Nearly 4% of the US marriages in
2012 are a result of eHarmony.
Overall, eHarmony
has successfully
leveraged the power
of analytics to create
a successful and thriving
business, and in this case,
analytics is at the
core of this business.